à 52 ans jean marais est ce que on
commence à faire un bilan
non j'avais dit pourtant si nous le t1
un coup d'oeil à l'arrière est ce que
vous pensez parfois que vous auriez pu
mener votre vie professionnelle
autrement
non je serai à refaire je ferais
exactement tout ce que j'ai fait
on dit que vous ne faites pas de milan
que vous ne regrettez rien mais l on
regrette jamais rien je regrette d être
des êtres qu'on aime et qui disparaît
swiss a gagné mais le les choses
je n'ai jamais eu la chance je crois on
peut tenir dans complet beaucoup d'être
exceptionnelle oui dans le milieu
artistique en particulier vous avez
rencontré
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance dans ma vie
je trouve ça hyper ça qui a dominé ma
vie c'est la chance et je le reconnais
j'en suis heureux des espèces des toiles
et si vous n'aviez pas été comédien si
je crois que dans ma jeunesse je n'avais
pas pu être comédien avineri bras
intéresser du tout mais à l'heure
actuelle si je n'étais pas d'enrayer
serait plainte
vous êtes déjà principe mais disons que
jean marais comédien et phase peut-être
jean marc épingle pour l'instant non et
des gens plutôt que je suis un meilleur
peintre que
le comédien et jean-marie quand on saute
et je trouve que je suis exactement
pareil je me jeunes eux mêmes ni comme
comédienne comme peinte
c'est pour cela qu'un jour les autres
peines et les autres lecteurs mais moi
personnellement j'ai jamais
j'ai toujours plutôt souffert de moirans
temps comédienne est ce pour cela grince
et j'ai enfin comme une distraction donc
je n'attends pas jugement est jeune
femme
mais qu'entend comédien j'ai fait
presque tout ce que j'ai voulu faire en
tant que peintre j'ai pas encore fait
c'est vous
est-ce que l'oeuvre de jean marais
peintre est une oeuvre très abondant
bien pas du tout parce que je peux très
lentement
j'ai un peu comme un maniaque presque en
tirant l'avant et je fais du figuratif
et de l'abstrait mais de la même même
technique que je un abstrait jeu mais je
peux mettre deux ou trois ans à le faire
alors à ce tarif là je peux pas pas
beaucoup
et les tableaux de jean marais se
trouvent at il chez des amis ou dans mon
grenier ma carrière l'acteur je pourrais
tenir demain pâtre je crains pas demain
on s'est toujours considéré comme un
apprenti est à goma l'accident je me
suis toujours trouvé un accident j'ai
toujours été étonné d'être là aussi bien
au théâtre au cinéma et au théâtre au
cinéma partout
sur ces merveilles je trouve la vie
merveilleuse d'ailleurs je dis pas ça
comme une critique
je suis toujours étonné et uhry d'avoir
que j'ai de vrais sujets et les amis que
j'ai des choses que j'ai je suis une
injustice je suis injustice vivante
en général les gens se plaignent de la
justice quand ils ont les malheurs moi
je plains de la justice vis-à-vis des
autres je trouve que je suis majoritaire
c'est à dire que j'ai eu tellement le
champ de la vie que je suis nul
[Musique]